there's no better way to get acquainted
with the cast of norse gods than to let
them
introduce each other to us
by means of putting out each other's
personal shortcomings and character
flaws
the rules of the gods are after all not
as clear-cut and one-dimensional as
popular treatments and assumptions often
suggest
it is their personalities that make them
unique memorable individuals not what we
might call their powers or abilities
now looking up the name of any god in a
popular print or online encyclopedia
will lead one very quickly to a short
definition such as god of thunder for
thor or goddess of love for freyja
but the gods are never given such titles
in our authentic old norse sources
it is only we modern readers who have
tried to impose these definitions by
role on the norse gods
tic thor for an example
his name does literally mean thunder
and it is exactly cognate with or from
the same ancestor word as the english
word thunder
in other words the ancestral word that
became english thunder also became old
norse thor
and likewise his great hammer with which
he smashes the skulls of god's enemies
is named lightning or so we assume is
the original meaning of its name which
an old norse is
this bears a close resemblance to and a
close relationship with
the russian word molniya lightning
as with other word relationships i
discuss here this is not to suggest that
the norse word is borrowed from the
russian or vice versa
but that both come from a common shared
root in the ancestral
proto-indo-european language
so at an early unrecorded stage we can
assume that thor was closely associated
with the natural phenomena of thunder
and lightning
and yet
in our ridden sources in old norse he is
associated with thunder only one time
during his duel against his stone-headed
enemy
which we covered in the first lesson of
this course
there thor is said to appear amid
thunder and lightning
otherwise thor does nothing associated
with thunder or lightning
by contrast the eras give us a strong
sense of his personality
thor is a man who hates lies and prefers
to deal directly with his enemies
thor is a man with a huge appetite for
food and for drink
and thor is an exemplary upholder of the
norse ideal of manliness he is what the
norse call atrenger
thus we know thor and likewise the other
gods and supernatural beings of the
norse cosmos
very well as a character as someone
whose personality and actor might assume
on a screen
but our simple contemporary ideas of
which god is god of what and which
goddess is goddess of what
are based mostly on the meanings of
names and not on the behavior of these
beings and the only real sources
available to us
so it is best to let go of trying to put
labels on the gods and try to get to
know them more as one would get to know
the characters and motivations of people
in a novel or biography
let's let the gods introduce each other
to us in a story in which
they mock one another
this is in a poem collected in the
poetic edda that is called lokasena
now an old norse senna is a truth
telling and loka is the possessive form
of loki's name so this is loki's
truth-telling
though the truths in question are not
pleasant and some might be exaggerated
to have a more caustic effect
the scene in this story is much like
that in a celebrity roast where all the
participants know one another and are
basically at peace
but show how well they know each other
by making knowing digs and jabs at the
other
yet there is also a sense of foreboding
that hangs over even these bitingly
humorous interactions
for we know that loki will do much worse
than insult the gods ragnarok when he
leads their enemies to kill them and at
the very feast where he pokes fun at
their sexual indiscretions
he also admits to causing the murder of
the beloved god balder
so one even
all the gods and goddesses were gathered
together for a great feast
but here in the peaceful realm of the
gods with gold as the very light for
their banquet was the dark figure of
loki
loki is a shape-changer who might take
many forms
although we know about his basic or
natural form is that he is supposedly
handsome and will have scars around his
lips for when they were sewn shut
in one of the few viking age artistic
depictions that we think depict a
specific god the synoption stone from a
viking age find in denmark
we see a man with curly or wavy hair a
long twisted mustache and scars around
his lips
well during the splendid feast loki took
exception to the generous praise the
gods were heaping on their wait staff
and he killed one of the servants
in our less classist society we might
react more strongly to a waiter murdered
before our eyes but the gods are still a
little upset and they shake their
shields at loki and shout at him and
drive him out into the forest before
they come back inside to resume their
feast
we have to remember that we're dealing
with a society with different ideas
about virtue and honor than our own and
not all murders are regarded as equally
murderous or equally condemned
for a high status being such as the god
loki to murder a mere servant isn't
really even a notable crime none of the
gods bring it up again
but what he has done is disturbed their
peace and shed blood in a place where
they were at their ease
his expulsion seems more in the way of
shunning a guest who doesn't know how to
behave at dinner than the exiling of a
psychopathic killer
but in the night
wookie returned to the door of the hall
and there he met the surviving waiter
this servant told loki that if loki went
inside once again
the gods would take whatever slanders
look he spoke about the gods and wiped
those slanders right off on him
loki declared however that he would go
inside and insult the gods so he barged
in and the gods fell silent when they
saw who it was in the doorway
here is what loki said
i come thirsty into this hall i loki
after a long road to ask the gods to
offer me just one drink of their famous
mead
why are you so silent you proud gods why
do you say nothing
you ought to show me to my seat at such
a feast or else order me to leave
notice the sarcasm apparent in the
statement here with loki the recently
cast out murderer taken on the role of a
poor wanderer seeking hospitality
this hospitality is in fact an essential
and sacred tenet of norse society but
the obligations go both ways a certain
behavior is expected from the guest as
well
certain behavior
includes not murdering the waiter
serving you at a feast
so loki is enacting a trope not
unfamiliar in norse or modern literature
where the defiler of a virtue takes a
stand for the rightness of his own
entitlement to others virtues
the first one to respond to loki's taunt
was the minor god bragi
a minor figure associated with poetry
he told loki that there was no seat for
him at the god's banquet the gods knew
who they wanted to share an evening's
drinks with
this is when loki half showed the
mysterious ace up his sleeve
he said
do you remember odinn when in bygone
days we blended our blood
you told me then that you would never
taste a drink that was not served us
both
this statement of loki's is in fact the
only attestation of this pact that loki
and the one-eyed odin had made at some
point for unknown reasons
whatever the motivation for this pact
it may be the reason why odinn keeps
loki around in the first place
for we are told that odinn survives on
wine alone
so if odinn honors this pact then
perhaps odinn would starve without this
resented blood brother
and odin in fact acknowledged loki's
assertion and responded
get up vedar
let this father of wolves take a seat
and have a drink
let's not let loki slander us here in
aguero's hall
here odinn was speaking to his son vidar
odinn already knows that vidar will
avenge odin's own death by killing
loki's son the great wolf fenrir
ragnarok
thus odinn bowed to his agreement with
loki but at the same time odinn was
clearly reminding his fellow gods of
loki's ultimate position as an enemy
within the hall of the gods
and so the always silent vidar stood and
served loki a drink
but before loki took the first sip
loki addressed the gathered gods with
these words
hail gods and goddesses all the high and
holy asia
except for that one god who sits
farthest down the bench that one there
bragi
bragi chose appeasement in response to
these hostile words
he offered loki three gifts a fine horse
a sword and a ring in exchange for not
further slandering any of the gods
loki only found a new opportunity to
insult him for this asking where a
coward like bragi could have gotten such
fine treasures to bestow on loki
after all it is the brave man the ready
fighter the reckless raider who acquires
fine treasures and might seek to
increase his standing by giving them to
powerful men
loki is implying that bragi is a coward
by implying that he does not actually
have such honorable gifts to give
braggy threatened loki in response
asking him if you'd like to take this
outside in terms not unfamiliar to
anyone who's ever witnessed a bar room
brawl
but loki called him a bench warmer a man
who's brave while he's sitting
wookie said that bragi ought to go ahead
and take a swing if he was brave enough
no swing got taken and bragi's wife
not is slandered loki here at this
divine feast
edun is known to us as the one who keeps
the gods magical apples which they eat
like the greek gods ambrosia in order to
remain youthful
we will encounter ethan and her apples a
few more times in other myths
but here she is merely the first of
several goddesses to withstand loki's
insults
for all the goddesses loki's insults are
materially the same
he accuses them all of promiscuous
sexual behavior
now
there is evidence from other preserved
myths to back up loki's specific taunts
of the male gods he may be pointing out
real failings of theirs
but the generalized and repetitive
sexual insults that loki makes about all
the goddesses may just be bluster
specifically he accused ithun of
sleeping with her own brother's killer
she did not take the bait and chose
instead to try to calm her husband if
loki's insult is true
we don't know who her brother is or what
occasion look he was referring to
remember that not all the myths known to
the poets have been preserved
but anyway this ended loki's interest in
insulting this couple
now geven an obscure goddess tried to
ply loki with compliments
and said he was a cheerful fellow
beloved by everyone
but loki told her that he knew about a
time she slept with the man in exchange
for a necklace
this might be true enough as the only
other substantial mention of gavin comes
from snorri storlasson's prozetta
there we read that she slept with a
particular swedish king
and in exchange was allowed to take as
much land for her own as four oxen could
plow on a day and a night
but four of her own sons with an
anti-god happened to be oxen so she used
her mighty supernatural oxsons to plow
her out a huge island out of sweden
she moved the island to denmark where it
became zealand the island copenhagen is
on
one-eyed old odinn himself spoke up
again now
he called loki crazy for insulting gebu
when odinn said she could foresee the
fates of all living things
this vague statement is not backed up in
any detail elsewhere
but loki countered with a well-placed
insult telling odinn that he was unfair
in his judgment of battles
odinn too often allowed the better men
to lose to their worst opponents
something odin ought not to do if he
truly had power over battles
odin responded without denying the
charge that loki was guilty of worse
that he had lived for years among human
beings as a cow and as a woman and that
he had given birth to children
odin said that this was the way of
living of a pervert
of a man who an old norse is called
an adjective that implies unmanliness at
any and all respects but especially in
sexual procludes
wookie responded however that odinn was
guilty of the same thing that he also
had practiced the quote perverts way of
living because odinn had practiced
womanly magic and lived and dressed as a
witch among the humans on the magical
island in eastern denmark that in modern
times is called samsu
the island's samsu comes up in the sagas
of the human heroes too
as a place of strange magic and strange
doings
it's hard to know how this particular
small island got this reputation in old
norse times as nothing about its natural
features today suggested as a place of
prominence perhaps some of the stone age
monuments of piled stone on the island
inspired the norse to think of it as a
place of magic and strangeness
now odinn's wife frigg responded to this
exchange of scandalous claims
she said that what happens on samsung
stays on samsu and that the two gods
really ought not to discuss such old
shames from their younger days openly in
front of everyone
notice that here and throughout this
tale the gods and even loki himself
don't ever deny the bad behavior they're
accused of
they don't say no i didn't they just
deflect the accusations so again very
likely we are to understand that these
imputations are true
loki of course responded the frig in the
usual way that he talks to the goddesses
here he told her that he knew about when
she slept with odinn's brothers
she responded that she would not have to
listen to such sliders if her son balder
with her to kill the man slandering her
but in return lookie only reminded her
that he was the reason
why she would never see her beloved son
balder riding home again
the goddess freyja now spoke up
she told loki that he was crazy to boast
of such evil as he had done in causing
baldr's death
she reminded him that frigg knew the
fates of everyone
exactly what odinn said about gabion
and loki retorted in the usual way i
said that freyja was a [ __ ] who had
slept with everyone
he said she was even caught sleeping
with her brother and that the gods heard
her break wind on this occasion norse
literature does make use of such blue
humor
now freya's father spoke up this is the
god njor
he said that it was only a small matter
whether women sleep with their own
husbands or with other men
but he tried to deflect the shame back
to loki because he was the god who had
borne children after all
loki told new earth shut up and he said
that on one occasion and a story unknown
to us
mouth was used as a urinal for the
daughters of one of the anti-gods
the arthur tried to deflect by drawing
attention to the sun he was proud to
have fathered the god
loki rebuffed even this attempt to save
face
he said that north's son freud was the
child of incest of njorth and his own
unnamed sister
but now tyr stood up to defend the good
name of north's son freud
as usual loki did not care to engage
with the defense
but just to insult tear back
he mocked tyr for being one-handed a
painful ability he suffered when he was
bitten by loki's wolf's son fender
we'll cover this in full in our lesson
on loki and his children
but toyota responded with admirable
equanimity
he said that he had lost his hand but
they were in the same boat because loki
had lost the sun that took it because
that sun is sitting bound in chains
forever until the great last battle
ragnarok
still loki heaped on the insults further
and told tyr that he loki had fathered a
son with tear's wife and that he would
never do anything for tear to compensate
him for it
we do not know the story if it is true
no wife of tears named anywhere
now it was freud's turn to speak for
himself after being defended by his
father in tear
freud told loki that loki would be the
next one chained up if he did not close
his mouth
but as we might expect by now loki had
ready words for freud
loki reminded freud that he had to pay
money for his wife and had to give up
his famous sword to his servant in order
to have her courted
this is a story we know well
covered in our lecture on the bonnier
freyr had nothing to say to this and it
was one of his own servants that spoke
up on his behalf now a servant named
bigfier who is not known outside of this
tale
the servant bookveir said that if he was
a wealthy powerful man like his master
floyd he wouldn't let loki get out of
this insult match unscathed
look he belittled him and said
who is this little fellow wagoness tail
scavenging for master scraps
you were always in your master's ear
always twittering away while doing your
mindless work
loki then said that big veer could
always be found hiding in straw when
battles start a pungent insult to his
manhood
at this point the god heimdall
interceded trying to do some damage
control
he said loki was drunk and this kind of
drunkenness makes every kind of man say
more than he means to
but loki refused the off-ramp and
insulted heimdall ii
his remarks on heindal are imperfectly
preserved or understood
loki said that heimdall had to stand all
the time with a muddy or damp back
we do not understand the reference but
maybe the real insult was just the fact
that he had to stand all the time as the
eternally vigilant watchmen of the gods
now skadi the wife daniorth spoke
she threatened loki in what we might
imagine to be a chilling tone of voice
that
you won't be speaking as a free man much
longer
the gods will bind you to the rock with
the cold guts
of your own son
but loki reminded the goddess scotty of
his battle against her own anti-god
father which loki said he was front and
center in
and he reminded her about another
occasion otherwise untold of in which
she begged loki to join her in bed
now the final goddess spoke to loki this
was the literally golden-haired
goddessive who is the wife of thor
she came forward with a horn full of
need and offered it to loki and said
hail to you now loki take this drink i
offer you of our good old need
do this rather than find fault with me
alone among all the gods and goddesses
loki took the drink but after drinking
it he said as we might predict he would
you would be unique civ if you actually
were wary and unwelcoming to other men
but i alone know how you were unfaithful
to your husband thor
and i
was the one you slept with
now the god's great fighter thor entered
the hall
thor is described traditionally as a big
red-bearded man equipped with his great
hammer with which he fights the god's
enemies and safeguards the homes of gods
and humans alike
thor bellowed at loki as he entered and
told him to shut up or be silenced by
his hammer
loki mocked thor first and told thor
that he would not look half so daring
during the last fight at agnarok when
the wolf will swallow his father odinn
thor then repeated his threat to smash
loki with the hammer
prompting loki to remind him of an
occasion in which thor embarrassed
himself
by hiding inside an enormous glove
this is a story we will return to in
detail and it is related to loki's next
insult to thor
which is that thor could not open a bag
of food on that same occasion
thor repeated his threat to smash loki
with the hammer after which loki said
i've spoken to the gods and the god sons
said everything i dared to say
but it's because of you thor that i'll
leave
i know you
and you alone
mean your threats
now we are told that loki hid himself in
a waterfall disguised as a salmon but he
was caught by the gods
the gods turned one of his sons into a
wolf and made lapsan kill another of
loki's sons then they tied loki up with
the intestines of that murdered son
then a venomous snake was tied up over
loki's face to drip poison onto him
below
loki's wife sigen who has no other known
role
would sit beside him and catch the
poison in a large container
but she would now and then need to empty
it and when she would do so
loki would tremble
and this would cause earthquakes as the
poison dripped onto his trembling face
this is one of the rare norse myths that
contains an explanation for a natural
phenomenon
modern readers sometimes wonder if a
tale in which the gods were all insulted
and made to seem less than perfect could
actually be a relic of the pagan era
some have suspected that this poem must
have been composed by a christian who is
contemptuous of all the old gods
but there is a rich tradition in many
polytheistic societies including india
and ancient greece
of acknowledging the imperfections of
the different gods especially since
different worshipers will favor
different ones and perhaps have friendly
or not so friendly ideas
about why their particular favorites are
the best
plus the language of the poem in which
this tale is told lokasena
is in fact archaic enough that it was
likely composed in the late 900s a.d
before the conversion to christianity
so believers in the norse god seem to
have had a complicated relationship with
their gods just as their gods did with
one another and with the anti-god beings
who are rivals but also parents to most
of the gods as we will discuss more in
the next lesson
in ruthlessly insulting one another the
gods also behave not too differently
from human beings and the sagas and
norse heroes
many of the sagas of poets the saga of
gunlaw or the saga of bjorn both written
in the 1200s
feature poets who insult each other very
publicly in elaborately constructed
stanzas about each other's real and
imaginary failings
bjorn saga in particular gives us the
spectacle of a man making up an entire
long stanza about how his hated
competitor is the son of a fish his
mother ate
so in lokasena we see the gods
interacting in a way that highlights
their shortcomings but their
shortcomings like ours may define their
personalities and other stories where we
meet them including
the honorable and honest to
who we know has given up a hand to
imprison the monstrous wolf fenrir
the ever vigilant watchmen haimdall who
we hear hints might have sacrificed his
ear for unknown purposes
the cynical warmongering odinn who isn't
afraid to dabble in forbidden or
dangerous magic and lore
including the lord that he sacrificed
his own eye to gain
the hearty but simple thor who's always
ready with a hammer but not as ready
with his tongue
in his battles on behalf of gods and
humanity alike he does of course get
lastingly hurt
we know from the first tale we looked at
his deal with
that he suffers from shrapnel embedded
in his head
and then there is loki the author of
devastation and chaos the murderer who
is also at home trading barbs with his
victims families
he is a liar and his compulsive lies
have come at a price
he will be imprisoned beneath the earth
with snake's venom falling on his face
and before that a group of dwarves sewed
his lip shut for his awful lies
the tales of norse mythology are woven
from the threads of these personalities
of these gods and goddesses and also
from the threads of their injuries
as noted just now many of the gods
including the most important have
sustained distinctive
life-altering losses of limb or function
the gods are not holy good not in
character and not in body
and not in their family relationships
either
even in our own lives we may find that
we are often in conflict with the people
we know the best and are most closely
related to and the gods are no exception
consider loki who has already been
responsible for the murder of balder and
will directly kill another of the gods
ragnarok
yet loki has sworn to a strange blood
brotherhood with odinn who will not
drink without loki
as we continue to explore the gods
relations with their enemies we'll see
that some enemies of the gods are even
more than the gods partners in drinking
they are also often the god's parents
and lovers